don't be reading books on how to become
a parent trust me
once the baby's here it's almost like
you know it just comes naturally
cardi b dishes out parenting advice
and gets one super luxurious mother's
day gift from her man offset
the rapper teamed up with reebok for a
super cute mommy and me capsule footwear
collection
and in honor of the launch the proud
mama opens up about what she has learned
so far
raising her two-year-old daughter
culture how do i make time for mother
daughter bonding
any little time that i get i just spend
it
that little bitty time is always a bond
you know what i'm saying
even like if i had a long day like today
was a long day
like at night you know what i'm saying
just chilling
laying next to your kid playing tickling
them
smelling their feet the grammy winner
also
shares this super relatable advice when
it comes to moms
keeping their kiddos entertained ice
cream
whatever the hell they want give it to
them the clip also featured some
sweet behind the scenes mommy daughter
moments
[Music]
thank you you're so beautiful look at
your face
and get ready to feel all the feels
because when cardi was asked what advice
she wants to pass
down to her daughter she had this to say
you're beautiful you're smart
you got successful parents the whole
world loves you
ain't no way you can make your dreams
come true and if all that wasn't sweet
enough
get this on sunday cardi's hubby offset
posted this sweet tribute to his leading
lady on instagram
quote happy mother's day my beautiful
wife you do a great job of raising our
beautiful culture
the way you love your family is god's
work i'm blessed to have a real one
i love everything about motherhood but
come on
this is offset we're talking about so
you know he delivered a sweet message
and a lavish gift check out what the
migos rapper gave his wife
an orange crocodile print hermes birken
bag
oh yes honey cardi showed off the
stunning accessory on her insta story
sunday night and
thanked her man oh snappity snap snap
and speaking of mommy and me back in
2020
for her second birthday culture received
her first hermes birkin bag from her
famous mom and dad
[Music]
look look this is yours
look
[Music]
but when e.t caught up with the up
wrapper in 2019
when culture was still a baby she
insisted that it isn't
all glam all the time you know you buy
so many clothes for babies
and then like the couture stuff
and the expensive name brand stuff you
put it on her
and then it's like right away she throws
up she drools or she might crap on it
and she just end up being in the in a
target outfit you know like in a target
onesie
my best pictures and videos of her is
she's like in a damn
[Music]
pajamas